[Music]
[Applause]
all right I'm looking for Jackie dr.
Mann Jackie dr. Minh Jackie oh hi Jackie
what a coincidence that you're right
there hi how are you stand up please do
you mind
I won't frighten you how you doing nice
to see you were you from okay how far is
that about an hour's drive okay
it was a big commitment for you to come
to this show did you fly here on a jet
no jet pack jet pack very nice okay
who's this guy with you hey how are you
I'm gonna fight him in the parking lot
after the show bare-chested it's what we
men do all right
Jackie are you ready to play basic-cable
name that tune okay Kesha is a close
personal friend of mine but if I tried
to play this hit of hers without paying
her lawyers would sue me until I die old
and penniless guys would you play a
place okay which Kesha song did that
kind of sound like but it's not actually
sure that sounded like daeyoung okay but
I assure you it was our own original
song we have a fatal illness here to
perform it is the singer who just
returned from a 40 city tour of every PF
Changs location on the east coast I hate
this guy mr. brian lefeve I hear your
labor process bile to the rhythm of bass
it's most unfortunate your AAA sponsors
here in this place Hawaii scoring some
coke let's exploit the evening to the
fullest like we have a fatal illness he
can't carry a tune my only talent is
public urination alright
it's a horrible man well Jackie you did
win you did get it right so Andy would
you tell Jackie what her prizes straight
from our clothing factory in the
Shandong Province it's some defective
coated merchandise
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there you go very nice to meet you yeah
enjoy that that's good Ava
Grayson is Ava Grayson here Ava Grayson
Ava Oh Ava Grayson all right up here I
can move all right hi how you doing good
to see you how are you come on out here
I want to talk to you if you don't mind
all right
wow you're tall people around Ava were
you from Vancouver oh I love Vancouver
yeah yeah I love Canada but Vancouver's
a fantastic town so you came here to LA
just to see this show for no other
reason okay good enough for me don't ask
too many questions how long have you
been here since about 1:00 okay and then
you came right to the show and then once
you're done with the show you're going
right back to Vancouver perfect I'm a
deluded idiot who is this gentleman
right here that's Chris yes is Chris
with you okay I'll fight him as well
ladies I will fight all of your
boyfriends in the parking lot after the
show
why is everyone into that idea the guys
are like he looks easy I'll do it are
you ready to play ever
okay this song made Billy Joe a huge
star and if we play the actual song
would be the victims of a huge lawsuit
and man oh man you don't want to get
sued by that guy who plays the piano man
[Music]
all right Ava can you identify that
Billy Joel song that it sort of sounds
like but it's not in a court of like and
prove it
piano man all right you and many
intellectual property attorneys may know
it as piano man but I can assure you
this is our own totally original tune
called tuba guy it blow on your tuba
you're the tuba guy blow on your tuba
this way
cuz we got a hankering for tupa tunes so
well on that horn like a free yeah I've
been arrested 12 times for stalking judd
hirsch I just hate him so much
not half as much as I hate myself and II
tell Eva what she won it's a jar of
Croom Norway's best-selling breakfast
spread / insect repellant
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow you're gonna love room it was so
nice meeting you and I will fight you in
about 20 minutes
[Applause]
hey nice to see you how you doing were
you from Andrew I'm from Los Angeles
okay so no commitment at all to be here
Andrew what do you do I'm a film student
Oh incredible what's your favorite film
of all time uh death becomes her oh okay
that's a great movie yeah it's a good
one are you gonna be a film director
yourself someday I hope okay will you
cast me in something of course just in
the background I'll just lean in and
kind of wait yeah steel focus and then
we not again and ruin your movie all
right here we go you ready to play I am
okay I personally asked the Red Hot
Chili Peppers if we could play this song
but when I wondered if they'd give it
away for free
they laughed and hung up on me gentlemen
[Music]
okay now Andrew which famous Red Hot
Chili Peppers song did that sort of
sound like but definitely wasn't give it
away now all right yeah yeah that kind
of sounded like give it away but my
lawyers have insisted I tell you it was
actually our own completely original hit
pay it forward let's hear it pay it
forward is a filmer Kevin Spacey have
you seen the movie pay-it-forward lately
got a copy can i watch it with your
doctor but the blu-ray and the to
pretend they get set for a quarter pay
it forward pay it forward pay for now
yeah
yeah so he's off I hate him
Andy tell our friend here what do you
want well it's from the Oscar Mayer
executive collection it's this briefcase
full of hot dog
[Applause]
and joy can I have some of those I
haven't had a hot meal since the Clinton
administration all right you'll go away
if we ignore